Hey folks, right up top—I have some opinions about
Monday’s bans, and those opinions obviously didn’t
fit into this video because it’s a precon review.
I made a separate video that went up on my Patreon
that gave some of my thoughts, and I also included
a portion of that video at the end of this one,
so you can stick around for that if you want
to know some of my thoughts. With that said,
let’s talk about the preconstructed commander deck
from Duskmourn that my patrons picked out for me
to review—Endless Punishment. What I’m going to
do in this video is talk about what this deck
is trying to do, what I like about the deck, and
what I’d change about the deck to improve it. This
particular deck sees Wizards of the Coast delving
into an archetype relatively unexplored in precons
of the past—group slug—and this particular deck
is pretty powerful showing. This begins with the
commander—Valgavoth, Harrower of Souls is a 4 mana
4/4 flier in Rakdos colors with “Ward—Pay 2 life”
and “Whenever an opponent loses life for the
first time during each of their turns, put a
+1/+1 counter on Valgavoth and draw a card.” The
first thing I notice about this card is that it’s
a strong payoff for a very specific action—causing
opponents to lose life on their own turns. There
are all manner of vaguely sluggy cards that this
can work well with, but there’s one specific type
of card that this really goes to town with, and
that’s cards that deal damage to opponents on
each of their turns. The prototypical example
in my mind is Sulfuric Vortex, but there are a
number of similar cards in Rakdos colors as well
such as Underworld Dreams type cards that deal
damage to players when they draw cards. These go
so hard with Valgavoth because they allow a player
to draw three additional cards per turn cycle, as
well as putting three +1/+1 counters on Valgavoth.
This will translate into a pretty back-breaking
amount of advantage, and since a lot of cards
that do this with Valgavoth cost three mana, it’s
theoretically quite easy to set this up by turn 4.
Going into this deck, I was kind of curious how
much of this sort of thing this precon would be
packing, and the answer is honestly more than I
expected. There are 11 different cards that I’d
expect to trigger life loss more often than
not on an opponent’s turn, and an additional
15 cards that will at least sometimes trigger
life loss on an opposing turn. Beyond these,
there are an additional 10 cards that will
cause some sort of life loss to opponents
at sorcery speed, and it seems like this sort
of incremental chip damage is how this deck is
looking to close out the game. A small part of
this package seems to be a combination of cards
that draw opponents additional cards and cards
that damage opponents when they draw. This is
backed up by a beefy removal suite that packs
answers for a wide range of threats. Finally,
a small package worth of lifegain is here to keep
the deck alive when the heat turns up. Overall,
this deck is looking to build advantage with its
commander while gradually knocking down opposing
life totals through a broad range of different
cards that can dish out incremental damage.
So that’s the game plan, but how do I like what’s
going on here? Overall I like it quite a lot,
actually. I knew going in that with the potential
power of the deck’s commander, a lot of the
quality of the deck was going to come down to how
far the deck leverages its commander synergies,
and I’m not unhappy with where it’s at. As I
mentioned there are 11 cards that will trigger
Valgavoth on most opposing turns, which is a
decent count. Archidekt’s built-in hypergeometric
calculator tells me that this means a 57% chance
of having one of these in the deck’s opening hand,
and a 78% chance to find one of these in the
first five draws of the game. Given that all
of these except for Kaervek the Merciless cost
five or less mana, this means a high probability
of being able to set up a hefty draw engine
by turn 5. I do note that the number of these
cards at three or less mana is only four, and
this makes a lot of sense—these cards combine
with the commander to produce a value engine that
will run away with games if unanswered, so I can
understand why Wizards of the Coast would want to
avoid a lot of the lower cost options. Though this
precon does include easily the most powerful of
these, Kederekt Parasite, which is unexpected but
cool—as a group slug enjoyer, I love to see this
powerful tech piece printed widely in a precon.
Looking at the other 15 Valvagoth enablers,
there’s a wide variety of different effects
here. Six of these are Blood Artist effects, which
make a decent bit of sense here—the deck packs a
good bit of removal and it also runs a relatively
high creature count of 32. The deck doesn’t have
much self-sacrifice, but I expect that it should
still manage to get triggers often enough for
these to feel useful. The rest are a mixture of
different things that will lead to occasional
life loss on opposing turns. Overall, these have a
good bit of variety, and oddly I feel like that’s
a good thing with a commander this potent. A lot
of players building Valgavoth are going to default
to cramming as many every-turn-pings as possible
into one deck, and though this does maximize the
possible Valgavoth triggers, it also flattens
the play pattern of the deck into one that is
predictably brutal for opponents. This will
lead to the deck being enemy #1 at all times
and not having many cards dedicated to the backup
plans that will inevitably be necessary against
competent opponents. By contrast, having a more
diverse range of Valgavoth enablers means that
this deck’s play patterns and relationship with
its commander are more textured to opponents,
and a lot of these enablers can also serve
useful purposes outside of enabling Valgavoth.
So, the instant speed ping plan looks pretty good
to me. As I mentioned earlier, this deck’s removal
suite is likewise pretty good—it has seven pieces
of targeted removal, four board wipes, three
removal engines, and one Kardur. He’s not exactly
removal, but he removes some annoying scary things
from my presence by sending them at a different
player for a turn, and that’s basically the
same thing, right? There’s also Brash Taunter, I
guess that’s a removal engine if your opponents’
creatures are puny. Beyond removal, the deck also
has moderate amounts of ramp and non-commander
draw. This is a deck that’s gonna be drawing a
lot of cards and wanting to pay a lot of commander
tax, so having a healthy collection of mana rocks
is absolutely a good thing. Non-commander draw is
also good—expecting to have the commander in play
at all times is highly optimistic, and fitting
in a healthy share of other draw is also good.
Finally, I support the choice to have some amount
of life total stabilization here as well, which
includes a few different sources of life gain.
This is a deck that’ll attract attacks, and
it’s good to be able to weather a bit of that.
Finally, the mana base here looks quite solid,
if a little tap land oriented. In the lands alone
we see 25 symbols each for red and black, which
are fantastic counts. There’s a lovely selection
of different dual lands—a tango, a cycler, a
checkland, a pain land, a fast land, a reveal
land, an Odyssey filter, and most exciting of all,
a Graven Cairns, Future Sight art. This is great
variety in lands for a two color precon. As far as
utility lands go, the deck runs Leechridden Swamp
and Shivan Gorge to go with Valgavoth, a Witch’s
Clinic to grant lifelink, and Spinerock Knoll as
a hideaway land. There are some minor tweaks
that could be made to tune up this mana base,
and I’ll be doing one of them in my upgrade
on this deck, but honestly this manabase is
going to play just fine right out of the box. I
playtested the deck 20 times to get a feel for it,
and in the vast majority of these the deck felt
pretty great, curving out relatively smoothly,
setting up threats and engines pretty
consistently, and seeming generally
well-poised to push later into the game. In some
ways I find this deck tricky to evaluate because
it seems like a strong deck, but also a deck that
will be a lightning rod for opposing removal and
attacks. However, keeping that in mind gives us
a good idea of where to start with upgrading,
so with that said let’s get into the
things I’d do to try and improve this deck.
For the rest of the video I’m going to discuss
parts of the deck I don’t like as much,
and changes I’d make to fix those parts. In
previous precon reviews I’ve subbed out 20 cards,
but in this one I’m going to drop that down
to 15—this base is just really solid and 20
would feel like changing the deck much more than
needed. With that in mind, let’s get into some of
the cards I’m not as thrilled by in this, starting
with basically a whole category of card—Sorcery
speed slug cards. These are cards that deal damage
to opponents, but usually or always on our turn
rather than our opponents’ turns, and which thus
can’t trigger Valgavoth. These cards do have a
valid place in the deck—obviously Valgavoth
won’t always be in play, and cards that slug
opponents on our turn might be better than their
instant-speed counterparts sometimes. However,
I do hold these to a higher bar than instant-speed
options, and that is a bar that simply is simply
not met by most of these. Enchanter’s Bane
is theoretically an enchantment hate option,
but in practice it seems undertuned and gives
opponents too many ways around being harmed by it.
Fear of Burning Alive is a cute potential damage
amplifier, but this deck doesn’t have enough ways
to enable Delirium, and without Delirium it’s
basically just a 6 mana 4/4. Combustible Gearhulk
is a likewise fun card, and I love it in my Radha
deck whose average mana value is stupid high, but
it too costs a lot of mana and this deck doesn’t
want the draw enough to warrant its inclusion.
Speaking of draw, Stormfist Crusader feeds the
whole table cards, which might be okay in a
draw hungry deck, but this deck has powerful
enough draw in the command zone that giving
opponents resources isn’t worth it. I exclude
Spiteful Visions for similar reasons—that one
actually is a potent Valgavoth enabler, but
in a group slug game plan you don’t want to
be giving your opponents resources to fight
you with, because you will be attracting the
ire of the whole table. There’s a reason why my
Rakdos group slug deck does exactly the opposite
of giving opponents cards. If you think you can
bribe opponents to be nice to you with cards,
I think you’re underestimating how much your
opponents hate seeing their life total spiral
downward, especially if it’s in tandem with you
drawing cards. A number of other cards I cut
because they don’t do quite enough to warrant
keeping around. Vial Smasher’s ability doesn’t
deal enough damage to make up for its otherwise
meager body, Star Athlete commits the cardinal sin
of giving opponents choices, and Tectonic Giant
is fine but a bit underwhelming here for four
mana. Grab the Prize and Light up the Stage are
fine as filtering and draw options, respectively,
but decidedly unimpressive to me compared
to some other options in this sphere. Some
other cards are strong but feel out of place
in this deck—Braids is a sweet value engine,
but this deck doesn’t run many tokens or ETB
permanents that would be desirable sacrifice
options. Kaervek can be nice if he sticks around,
but 7 mana is a bit too much to pay for what he
does for this deck. Finally, Barbflare Gremlin
is a card with potential, but this deck isn’t
set up well to break parity on the mana boost it
gives. Pro tip: doubling your opponents’ mana is
generally not recommended—Treasonous Ogre is a
reasonably popular card, and our gremlin friend
here gives a three times better rate for our
opponents to translate life for additional mana.
What goes in in place of these cards?
Well, most of my additions follow one
core principle—this deck will make opponents
square the hell up. One form of this is that
the commander easily forms many disgusting value
engines, and as a result will be a high priority
target for removal. One way I choose to
combat this is protection equipments,
specifically Swiftfoot Boots and Champion’s
Helm. The other way I choose to combat this
is Glimpse the Impossible which works as a
potential burst of mana, as well as serving
extra purposes of draw and blockers. I actually
dislike a couple of the cards I kept in the deck,
namely Rakdos Lord of Riots and Seance Board,
but these were kept because I expect this deck
to do a lot of recasting its commander and these
cards are undeniably helpful for that. Moving on,
I mentioned squaring up earlier, and aside from
removal the way I expect this to manifest is this
deck getting attacked heavily. Opponents do not
like feeling like they’re on a clock, and cards
that do consistent player damage over time will
trigger exactly that feeling. To mitigate that,
I’m choosing to add some defensive cards to the
deck, namely goad and lifegain. Goad also has
the side benefit of enabling the deck’s Blood
Artist effects, since opponents being in combat
with each other is a thing that often results in
creatures dying at no cost to the goading player.
Vengeful Ancestor is a classic goad-granter that
also triggers Valgavoth, and Frenzied Gorespawn
is another goad ETB creature with some added
utility. For noncreature options, Disrupt Decorum
is that lovely effect of goading everything, and
Spectacular Showdown is a similar card that can
also be used to suddenly kill an opponent with
an enlarged Valgavoth. For lifegain, Raphael,
Fiendish Savior is a lovely package—lifelink for
the commander and blockers in the form of devils,
and these devils can even enable Valgavoth
after they block. I’m also choosing to add
Tainted Bonds, which serves double duty as
life total stabilizer and Valgavoth enabler.
With defense and protection out of the way, let’s
talk about other Valgavoth enablers. I mentioned
earlier that a common choice for naive players
building Valgavoth will be cramming in as many
cards as possible that deal damage to opponents
on each turn. While I do think that going all
in these would amplify the deck’s weaknesses
to removal and opposing aggression, adding in
a handful of these to improve consistency still
seems useful now that we’ve contained the deck’s
weaknesses a bit. And I do mean a handful—as
I mentioned earlier this deck is already doing
pretty decently for Valgavoth enablers, and I just
want to add in a few more low-cost ones. Roiling
Vortex is a good enabler for Valgavoth that
damages players each turn, and I chose this over
Sulfuric Vortex because this deck has a decent
bit of lifegain that it’d be bad to incidentally
prevent. I’m also adding one of my pet cards—Rug
of Smothering—which performs the role of enabling
Valgavoth when opponents cast spells, along with
the similar Magebane Lizard. For a handful of
miscellaneous cards to finish things off, I added
the MDFC Hagra Mauling to replace Temple of the
False God, and I also added another removal spell
I really like in slug decks called Cut. It’s a mid
removal spell that can be cast from the graveyard
as a decent life loss spell, and I’ve found this
combo to be quite sweet—you get cheap removal for
something when you need it early and then a burst
of life loss later when you’re getting to the
stage of finishing off opponents. My final add
was a card I just like—Caustic Bronco. It’s a
draw engine, it can slug—what’s not to like?
So that’s my upgrade—improved enablers, more
protection, and some defensive options to keep
us alive through some irritated opponents. Even
without upgrades this is an impressive deck,
and it’s a deck that very clearly positions itself
as a table enemy. I like this about it—though the
commander has synergies that very much demand
removal immediately, which is an ever-common
commander dynamic I don’t care for as much, the
fact that this is paired with a gameplan that is
looking to whittle down life totals quickly
is pretty fun. I’m also interested to see
if Wizards of the Coast diversifies the
gameplans of precons—there have been a
few different aggressive ones over the past
year, and I hope we see more of that. Alright,
that’s all I have for this video. If you want
to hear my thoughts on Duskmourn as a set,
I was on a podcast with The Trinket Mage and
3/3 Elk last week, and a link to that is in
the description. With that said, here are some of
my thoughts on yesterday’s [Monday's] bannings.